but I won't go quietly
I'll battle till the end the
long-awaited season five of the crown is
here this installment brings us the next
chapter in these compelling characters
stories and with it even more
interesting and intriguing secrets so
stick around for everything that went
into creating season 5 of the crown
number one if you can we can understand
how actors develop strong opinions on
their characters and this is true for
Dominic West playing Charles as well
Dominic West said about being cast in
his role this is such a big show that
has had so many great performances in it
but he had hesitations earlier on in
production Dominic holds the position of
ambassador of the prince's trust a
charity of which King Charles is the
president when Dominic learned he was
going to play Charles he offered to
resign his position in case of a
conflict of interest West said that his
resignation offer was refused by a
letter from King Charles's private
secretary saying you do what you like
you're an actor it's nothing to do with
us it seems to us that Dominic took
great care in portraying his character
number two the devil is in the details
creating a believable character in The
Crown season 5 is a challenging task
with a set of Secrets but create a
believable world for those actors to
live in is a challenge with Secrets all
of its own set decorator Alison Harvey
says our job is to try and create the
world that the actors can sort of
inhabit we try and make that whole
environment feel believable Alison
describes the approach to creating a
world that is both believable for the
viewers and inhabitable for the actors
we start with the flooring the lighting
the big lumps of furniture ultimately
you end up with a paper knife it's like
moving house every day hopefully by the
end of it it looks like someone lives
there number three who could have seen
this coming when we think of the making
of the crown season 5 we think of the
great challenges faced by the actors and
the production team production for
season five of the crown had a major
setback in the final week of production
when 150
000 pounds worth of props were stolen
set decorator Allison Harvey recalled
one of the worst things that happened to
the season was three of the prop trucks
with our antiques got broken into
overnight and all all the Antiques were
stolen off the bat it was obviously a
nightmare because we had to try to
replace them quickly The Twist was that
when the crime was reported the police
said they didn't have time to
investigate the theft because they have
found a body in the river nearby the
body turned out to be a prosthetic
belonging to the production team of the
crown and was one of the items stolen
from the back of the trucks number four
these actors have a few tricks up their
sleeves Elizabeth Debicki had a secret
resource in preparing for her role as
Diana when describing how she took on
the daunting task of becoming Princess
Diana Elizabeth said China being the
most photographed person in the world at
that time there's just this incredible
amount of content that we have access to
the crown season 5 actors all seem to
need to develop a deep understanding of
what they think their characters are
going through at the time and it's a big
challenge at first Elizabeth Debicki
describes the task obviously it's not
just you open the portal and it's just
this huge tsunami of information that
comes in Elizabeth says the challenge
eventually starts to ease up until it's
time to start filming do you start to
sort of inhabit them and embody them and
all of a sudden you have to just make
this crazy leap number five unlike some
of his castmates Dominic West had a
secret Advantage he has actually met the
real life counterpart of his character
several times West said I've been in a
line to shake his hand a few times and
it's fascinating it's very useful to
meet the character you're playing
obviously number six this stuff is gold
we viewers of the crown season five or
any of the seasons might agree that the
resemblance between the actor's
portrayal and their real-life
counterparts is almost uncanny and maybe
because some of us as viewers remember
the events portrayed in season 5 of the
crown it can be a little too close for
comfort Imelda Staunton describes the
season it does start with people
questioning do we need the monarchy do
we need the queen and she has to ride
that particular storm what does this
Stormy Weather mean for the actors
Staunton breaks it down for us these are
tumultuous times within the family so
these are the difficult years some
viewers have expressed criticism around
the way these events have been portrayed
some claiming that the script has
moments of historical inaccuracy but the
crown season 5 actor Jonathan price
reminds us of this the public are well
aware that it's a drama it's not a
documentary number seven they got the
call most of the actors who have been
cast in The Crown season 5 and probably
the other Seasons too tend to agree that
they are initially excited to hear the
news that they got the role and then the
reality of the daunting task starts to
set in Dominic West was no exception and
had this to say about taking on the role
of Charles in the crown season five I
was slightly in despair how was I going
to get the physicality of this guy
because the only time I really look like
Charles is from behind because the hair
is just perfect Elizabeth Debicki shared
this story about when she got the news
as an actor your only moments of peace
and total Bliss are the 20 minutes of
when someone offers you the role and
you're on the phone and you're a million
miles in the air and you think it's just
everything you've ever wanted and
dreamed of obviously then you just think
but how do I do it number eight a tough
act to follow it can be hard for an
actor to step into a role that has been
done by someone else so recently or
maybe it's just hard for us viewers to
get used to it either way there's
something to be said for the challenge
so what's the secret here's what the
crown season 5 actor Imelda Staunton has
to offer we've also seen the first four
series of the crown so of course we've
got that in our heads as well as the
research as well as our own history of
looking at those characters those real
people so all those layers you've got
hopefully will carry us through number
nine we want to watch more carefully now
the task of the actors in The Crown
season 5 is to tell these stories and
their job can be enhanced great greatly
by a feeling of immersion in the world
of the story here's what the crown
season 5 actor Dominic West has to say
about stepping into the role that has
been built for them if you're dealing
with paperwork or in a meeting the stuff
that's printed on things which no one
will ever see that's the level of detail
that the props Department go to we can
only imagine the secrets buried in each
set and crop piece and we can probably
all agree with Dominic when he says so
much goes unseen and unthanked number 10
criticisms have Arisen around season
five of the crown for seemingly blurring
the lines between fact and fiction maybe
it's that season 5 covers a few events
that some of us can barely remember or
have read about the crown season 5 actor
Dominic West has to share the great
tensions that you see in this season
that Peter has written about is between
this 1950s outlook on the monarchy and
on public life and on marriage and the
modern day and how they Clash some of
the criticisms of season 5 have come
from people who are friends of Charles
and Camille like Dame Judy Dench season
5 actor Jonathan price explains those
particular criticisms came from not
having seen a second of film of this
series so why are these people speaking
out like this price ads the assumption
is that their friend that Prince Charles
would be damaged in some way this seems
understandable if someone has not seen
the show but only heard about some of
the details of the story Jonathan adds
all we are presenting in the crown is
what happened the crown season 5 has
brought us yet another compelling
collection of stories around these
historic characters and with it another
set of curious Secrets around how the
season was brought to life this is only
a short list of the tales from behind
the scenes so what did we miss what do
you think let us know in the comments
below